[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's up welcome back to my channel
and in this video i'm gonna be
interviewing a 24 year old man who is
financially free in property he's got
four properties that he's bought himself
he's also packaging and selling deals
every single month he's left his job
he's financially free and he's gonna be
sharing in this video exactly step by
step how he did it so that you can do
the same thing too so i hope you enjoy
the interview if you like my channel hit
the like button also don't forget to
subscribe enjoy thank you so much for
coming to my house
doing amazing things in property you've
gone from work in a normal job
you're now in you how old are you 24 24
you own two properties but more
importantly you're making how much
profit a month are you making
5 600 at the moment okay and that's a
combination of rent and also deal
packages
where did this all get started what made
you want to get into property it was
2019
we've renovated our own home not
intentionally trying to make any money
just just renovating this you and your
my partner right so shout out to her my
fiance yeah she made it what happened to
me first okay good massive support um
and yeah refinance the house i watched
your videos on youtube
and then i saw that you could refinance
your house and use your money to invest
in property so that was our main goal
and obviously watching your videos the
first thing i invested in was the
academy because i've been watching it
for like ages um
and then the bio favorite finance course
and all that sort of stuff and yeah
that's how it started so your first
property then so you just bought it to
live in yeah to live in yeah and then
the value went up a little bit over time
yeah and you thought hanging on here
so it's the rough figures 44 154 000. so
yeah and 15 on it and it revived 210 and
after how long
like six months so there's your like
accidental brl living in it yeah yeah
nice just to learn the house you're sold
now sold in that you're living yeah so
you start watching my videos and you
realize that you can invest with money
that you refinanced what did your
friends and family think about this
whole idea about going home they're
super skeptical right really skeptical
yeah really
you're a young guy um well i remember
signing up to the academy coming into a
mobile mum was like what are you doing
yeah because effectively the money that
you put into your education not just
your education but also into other
properties yeah was debt yeah and that's
the whole difference between good debt
and bad debt yeah um most people think
you get a job you had a decent job man
yeah yeah what were you working on
electrician right 40 grand a year very
nice so you had the perfect start in
life yeah yeah yeah i mean it was a
graph though it was yeah working hard
making 48 000 pounds
own a house you and your partner any
normal person in britain would say keep
working hard yeah pay off the mortgage
retire young and it will be this normal
corporate rat race
what was it that made you take the
plunge like when you've got your family
being skeptical the main drive for doing
it was i i worked away a lot so i worked
in glasgow for like three months and the
people i was around i could see they
weren't happy they were they've been
doing the same i've been doing for ten
years and they had children and um
you know i could tell that they wanted
to be having their children and it was
kept what they could achieve so if i
wanted to get further than where i was i
needed to be a director which was very
unlikely so the whole drive was to
invest in property so i could be there
for the children yeah
so when you refinance then how much cash
did you have in your day 50k yeah
and you spent about 10 12 yeah in the
academy yeah yeah and again
my opinion and everyone has to do what
that feels right for them but if you've
got 50k
40k with all of the training and
mentorship is going to go a lot further
than 50k you never know what you're
doing so i think i know your family
thought you were crazy well the first
deal i did i made the academy back in
equity in the house so talk to me
through that first deal though so it was
in hull yeah so we bought it for 63 000
and including the refurb legals and the
deposit for the bridging it was 40k so
literally about bang on right and when
we refinanced what's it bought 63 they
were the fees and then it refinanced it
ninety seven thousand five hundred
and so once it refinanced we left in
eleven thousand right nice yeah so you
pulled out most of your money yeah yeah
he did it again yeah again the that deal
is pretty much identical to the second
one because we bought a house on an
opposite street the 65
and the refurb was a bit more next we
used we had a proper good power team in
place and so i think that came to 45 all
in fees bridging deposits yeah and when
we refinanced it we financed 110 and we
left 9k in that both of them were about
30 percent and return investment perhaps
30 30
so you got so good at finding deals
um a lot of people started approaching
you yeah there's a guy called patrick
welch yeah yeah who's on the academy as
well and they were saying you know
thomas can you bring your brilliant
deals to us yeah we want to sell them
talk to them about how you're going to
code ill sorting and why you chose to do
that so the first deal i actually sold
was through patrick welsh and that was
when i was working full time so we sold
a biorefurbi finance deal near me in
york um the 5k so two and a half k each
and it was lying on a minute i've just
made two and a half
yeah and that's when i decided to leave
my job in january you know pursue deals
awesome right so you left your job and
you started packaging and that's a
really interesting thing as well about
deal sourcing packaging a deal and
selling it
it doesn't take that long
if you do just one a month you can
replace the average salary yeah so and
you're living proof of that you went
full time in january 2021 yeah to become
a deal sorcerer what was the biggest
struggle after quitting your job were
there times when cash flow was
was hard and i mean yeah so i left so
left in january and i was code deal
sourcing i think
did about four or five deals code deal
sourcing and then it reached a month
where no sorry two months where i didn't
sell the deal i didn't know if it was
the wrong patch or but i was going for a
bit of a rough patch you're trying to
get a good deal yeah and
and
it wasn't until then when i went on the
acmp
which it you know got a lot better so
tell me as well the story because that
was a classic couple of days what's the
acmp what's it stand for and what what
happened it's the accelerated coaching
and mentoring program yeah and it
basically sees where you are what what
courses you've done and where you want
to go to and you know what's preventing
you what problems you have it's almost
like a bespoke package to you at that
moment in time to push you further with
me with you yeah exactly smack around or
something yeah
a lot of people it's so funny how many
people like you didn't want to come on
windows on a wednesday night let's face
it because you were a bit like oh it's a
bit nerve-wracking what's the point i
don't want to do it but there's so many
academy members that don't want to come
and accelerate coaching and mentoring
because they know what's going to happen
then i wasn't really aware so i was just
[Laughter]
but i'm like right who's succeeding
who's winning all right we'll put you
over there who's struggling right we'll
put you over there what's happening
where you going
so it was quite a brutal couple of days
needed though
what happened so i remember i put my
hand up so where am i when you said you
know where are you now what's your
problems and i said well i saw a deal in
two months i'm quite worried and
um
what you've been doing and you looked at
midori there wasn't much in there and i
said you know i go to the gym in the
morning and walk my dog and you're like
so you're not actually starting your day
until 10 o'clock in the morning yeah and
just just basically i needed a shaker to
get my head back in gear yeah i think it
was getting too comfortable right yeah
it's a really interesting point as well
because i know now you're smashing it
that's why you're here but but that
decision when when not to quit your job
is such i think there is no right and
wrong answer no it depends on the person
some people when they quit their job
they're gonna go
crazy successful in property of all the
time other people not it's really
difficult for me to answer
what was it that made you decide january
was the time to quit your job um
i think it was just
working as an electrician and how hard
you work you know working weekends and
stuff and realizing that you know you're
not actually going to get any further
than you can't so soon as i can see that
you can make a lot of money for deal
sourcing and i've always had an interest
in property and
i just i just saw you know that it's
hard you can you can achieve a lot more
you know so it was this idea of making a
capped amount yeah and i knew how much
how hard i worked within you know being
employed if i put that into my own
business that i could sort of do yeah
well and that's another thing as well i
remember saying at the acmp to some of
the guys maybe you i was like if you
were your own member of staff you'd fire
yourself i think you set up fight
i'm like you're by yourself you don't
wake
like you can't do that you can't if you
want to be successful as a deal saucer
um so since the acmp what's happened
that was about three months ago now
um i just basically had a reboot i had
to put everything back back on paper and
just think you know what am i doing
wrong what's working what's not you know
took all the the comments from you know
some of the mentors there um that really
pushed me in the right direction and
then now i'm selling deals you know to
investors directly before the ncmp i was
doing the code deals
and scenarios investors and and yeah
it's just really worked pros and cons
between coding sourcing and deal
sourcing
coding sourcing the pros first if you
need it to be compliant so you can just
package the deal and then they'll sort
it out for you and then the negatives to
that is you know i'd like to know what's
happening and if you pass it you know a
deal to an uh code source they'll sell
it for you but i'd like to know what's
happening you know what's being sold
what's using the investor that's the
whole story behind it yeah when you're
signing for yourself you've got full
control so you know you can control
everything yeah and also you get paid
yeah yeah right yeah
you came on the samuel 365 mastermind
session yeah and i always ask everybody
i go around what are you doing what are
you doing what are you doing i said to
you what are you doing what's happening
and you spoke about when you spoke about
how many deals you sold i think you said
i made seven grand this month for
whatever it was yeah it lasted about
half an hour because everyone had so
many questions to ask yeah they've had
so many comments and questions and it's
been great people were like oh how do
you do this and ask me loads of
questions and that's why i wanted to
bring you on winners on a wednesday
because i thought actually
my subscribers could really benefit from
this yeah so talk to me about what is
deal sourcing and why did you choose
that strategy and and how how does one
start doing becoming a deal source from
scratch
so
obviously i've done the two deals in
hull and i felt ready that i could find
more deals for investors yeah i was
finding more deals than you know i could
take myself um
and yeah there's no point you know just
not taking these on so it's like
packaging them and selling them yeah and
so that's where you find a really good
deal you stack all the numbers you do
all the relevant due diligence that you
need to do so it's actually you know a
good deal yeah and your stacks and then
um you basically present to an investor
you know through um you may mail in nest
and where do you find where how do you
grow that mailing list because it's all
right for you to say oh i just know what
that's actually look that's a really
good point because before before i did
the anti um the acmp
and i didn't realize how much you need
to construct buying investors i was
controlling deals and not investors so
when i left the smp i was like 50
investors 50
and finding the deal so investors for me
is social media i think it's such a good
platform um even if you can you know
send people rough deals you've already
sold or deals you stacked yeah investors
online and again what you've done is
you've got momentum because
you've invested successfully yourself in
a couple of properties where you've
bought them added value refinance done
you've now done so you've successfully
sold to investors you've got a good
reputation in the community everyone's
talking positively about you oh i bought
a deal for thomas it's gone really well
and
i feel like the hardest deal is always
your first deal yes yes yeah it's
getting that first deal so with the br
uh when you're packaging and selling a
deal are these br ideals yeah that's my
bag really is bioreferred finance do you
do you deal with the project management
yeah the whole whole job yeah so you
manage everything together i have a
great build team that i found in hull
and they operate quite a lot around the
country yeah so your first project that
you did
your first vrr did that by myself
what happened so
i was still in the train you know i do
the work the south and you remember i'm
working full-time job i live in new york
i have my projects in hull yeah so i'm
like stretching myself here i mean we
did the refurb for only 15k yeah but now
i have a build team that will do the
full refurb for just over 20 for a
standard three bedrooms house you know
the whole shebang and it's just so easy
but you won't be involved exactly
exactly or maybe overseeing it but not
doing itself yeah but you know the
profession will do it yeah i was trying
to do tasks which i wasn't really
qualified in and you know probably have
more problems right down the line
they're not getting professionals do it
i've noticed that a lot of builders or
people within the trade say you were an
electrician for instance
feel like oh i could do this
but actually it's like no you can't yeah
you might be able to do the refurb or
maybe you can do part of the refurb yeah
but doing a refurbishment start to
finish you've got to find the deal
negotiate it you've got to make sure
that it values up you've got to do all
your due diligence you've got to there's
so much to it besides just the actual
refurb but a lot of builders feel like i
can do it but they end up working on
other people's jobs getting investors
rich whereas they could be doing
themselves if they just humbled
themselves a little bit yeah and i don't
mean to say not all builders are like
this but i can't get so many builders
they won't do the training they won't
pay a sources fee they won't because
they're like oh i could do it myself
it's like go on then knock yourself out
it's funny though because now i'd
happily pay a sourcing fee for a great
deal even if i don't find it i think
that a sourcing fee is nothing compared
to what you can make for a great deal
yeah you know there are bad sources out
there
that
ruin the reputation the reputation of
others by doing things wrong i'm sure
you've come across this or seen this
um yeah i think that comes down to the
building quote to be honest i think
especially by refurbished financing
you've got to get your building quite
right because they're normally the the
three figures is the purchase price the
refurb and the end value yeah and people
always underestimate the refurb and
overestimate the correct value and you
only have to overestimate by ten percent
and then understand and suddenly it
makes no money yeah you might as well
just buy a turnkey investment yeah
yeah you've got to get the numbers right
yeah so how do you do that
well i well i've i've had a good
conversation with my builder and we've
gone through a spreadsheet and now we so
if when i go to view a house i tend to
do a video inside i will send the video
to my builder and then i also go through
my spreadsheet and make sure everything
is ticked off and then it will pump out
a figure to make sure it's the exact
quotation to the pound what it's going
to be yeah we always add on a 20
contingency not 10
so make sure there's enough you know
buffer um but guys for anyone you said
about the refurb and builders wanted to
get involved i honestly have to hold
myself back so much to not get involved
with refurbs i think it's quite a nice
feeling getting involved with them yeah
they're seeing them products and knowing
you've worked on it but
the definition of a business is
something that can function with or
without you yeah if you're having to do
everything then it's kind of just a job
yeah it doesn't make financial it's not
a good financial decision yeah to do
that so how many deals on average are
you selling per month right now
well it's on average it's
so since i left the acmp i did a deal so
a deal per month but then this month
i've sold three deals in one month from
selling a very favorite finance deal to
an investor and the same investor said
you know i actually want two family nets
as well so this month alone i've made 9k
so you do on average three thousand
pounds per deal yes so over three months
since the asmp is 5k a month what about
could you judge extra for the project
management side of things
um
yeah but the one on the the deal i've
done in darlington the barry february
finance deal we've done it as a package
so we've discharged a straight 5k fee
for the deal and um hassle-free selling
the project management yeah yeah
um what does people the people that
skeptical at first like your mom that
was saying are you mad yeah
are they now won over or are they still
skeptical no they're they're very won
over they you know a lot of friends and
family want to get involved now yeah and
and it's just finding the time to make
sure we find them a great deal as well
because we do have over two what about
your mom so my mom really wants to get
involved now
you're brilliant yeah they do um so we
are working with them to try to find a
good deal and also you've made it seems
like a lot of friends through the
academy and through the training you've
got you're part of like a support bubble
like dan and patrick
you seem to have made a lot of good
friends yeah talk to me about that and
the importance of that
it's definitely yeah surrounding
yourselves with people like that because
patrick you know he's been a massive
help from the start with code sourcing
and dan you know he's just constantly
just building up saying you can do this
you got to keep going because everybody
because you know
representing the best of me right now
but everybody goes through rough patches
you know you know it's not it's not easy
and you do need a good support around
you to keep pushing you through their
rough patches
what's been the toughest point over the
last year or so
it was before i came to the acmp because
i remember speaking to patrick at that
course saying i think i'm going to go
back to doing two days a week be an
electrician
yeah and patrick was like nah nah i'm
going to speak to alice there now i
almost meant to listen he's going to
tell me you don't want to do that
because he was there as well yeah um
and
because i didn't sign a deal for two
months and you know you've got bills
you've got you know people to provide
for
and so that was that was really
difficult do you think if it wasn't for
the accelerated coaching and mentoring
program remember those two days if it
wasn't for that do you think you would
end up going back to work
definitely yeah i was just if i'll speak
in it i was gonna talk into reality yeah
so that would have sucked yeah you
wouldn't be here on wins on a wednesday
no chance no i would have probably gone
back being a full-time electrician yeah
oh man i know so what was it about those
two days that happened i think it's
because i didn't do a course in a while
and i was just you know when you just
you don't speak to people and you get
yourself into a bit of a hole and you
know you don't really feel like you get
out and you go to something that's
comfortable you know you can do it
because i was on the street for seven
years i knew what i was doing um
and then yeah i think to speak to
everyone i was thought nah i'm not doing
that i'm going to continue what i've
started and make sure it works and
finish it yeah it's something about
environment as well isn't it
there's a bunch of other people are very
successful and
isolation yeah you don't want to be
isolated you've got to have them people
around you because i'd have that
conversation with people that were you
know electricians they're like yeah come
back to the electrician you know that
it's not the same environment you're in
it's completely different yeah you know
out of all the training programs
besides acmp what's been what's been
your favorite one and why um biotherapy
finance yeah because they're the two
deals we've done really enjoyed both
projects and
you know the strategy works if you find
a good deal at the right price yeah well
the deal selling master classes that's
right yeah again yeah yeah the dcm you
know that's got me out of my job yeah so
to be fair that probably comes above the
bioreferred finance course yeah but then
i guess the strategies kind of go hand
in hand don't they so if you're
packaging and selling a buyer which
finance you need to be able to sell a
deal but you also need the all the
understanding of brr i think i mean by
doing the two barry february finance
deals first that really set me up for
deal salem because yeah i know by
february refinance inside out now so i
know how it works fully and i feel
confident when i said a deal to investor
so talking about the process in a
biofuture finance so what happens what
do you what are the key skills and
things you need to be able to do
making sure that you're not overpaying
for the property so you've got to make
sure you get in a really run-down state
i know at the moment it is quite
difficult with the market but you've
just got to really keep pushing through
and finding the right the property at
the right price and then it comes down
to the refurb knowing your refurb you've
got to speak to you know builders get
quotations or you know have a good
spreadsheet that you can you can do a
good building quote an estimate and then
it also also depends on the end value
and that all comes down to your due
diligence and making sure you chose the
right property how do you work out the
end value
typically for me it's sold comparables
on the road but if you're struggling you
can look for square footage and square
meters of the house and you can use you
know platforms online like property data
and um deal source as well um to work
out square footage per square meter
that's great yeah how do you feel you've
changed as a person because i know
you've been stretched a lot at times
over the last year or so um have you
changed as a person at all would you
feel um i think so yeah like i think
it's very easy
to
to start something i think it's going to
be easy and you've really got to push
through it to make sure you get the
results because
nothing's easy in life it's really not
you've got to really work hard to get to
get the good things yeah yeah
and i think i mean you've probably heard
me say before i say if you're going to
work hard anyway you might as well get
rich i know exactly
everything's hard it's
being on benefits is hard yeah it is
yeah having a job is hard running a
business is hard being fat is hard being
slim is hard everything's hard
life's not meant to be easy the key is
to say what kind of life do i want and
if you're gonna work hard anyway you
might as well be rich and you know
you've worked really hard you were
working really hard as an electrician
exactly yeah but now you're working
really hard on your business yeah yeah
um have you got any other properties in
the pipeline for yourself you're
planning on growing your own portfolio
anymore um to be honest we're going into
a joint venture now we've done bowie um
we've got a hmo six bed hmo conversion
in darlington beautiful and we've
purchased it for 105. we've just bought
it yeah we're complete this week on the
bridging oh wow you're a dark horse
aren't you yeah yeah
yeah yeah so we've completely gonna
complete this week 105 purchase the
refurb is going to come at 65 000 and
the end value is 240. nice so each of us
will leave about 10k in the deal but
it's going to cash flow about 1 200. so
six hundred pound each cash flow yeah
without a cash flow it's very nice what
i'm learning now is i actually wanna
have a power team around me because them
two deals i've done them on my own and i
actually like what i like bouncing off
someone and dan i get on really well
with so yeah and again dan another
academy member you're smashing it
absolutely smashing it's just been on
windows on the website as well so okay
and again that shows as well you've got
brr packaging and selling deals hmo
combining the strategies
joint ventures yeah another strategy
yeah what um
you know what what's the long-term
vision so my strategy now i'm going to
come straight on is buy your favorite
finance hmo yes because
bio-focus finance is a family like he's
good but it is slow pound
at the moment now more passive income
through hmos but they're also recycling
my cash at the same time to think that
this all started from one little house
that you earned yeah yeah and so
actually can i refinance it and then can
i put some of the money into my
education and into properties so from
that one refinance we've stretched it to
do more poor deals now yeah which was
50k yeah it's not an amazing amount of
money no some people might go oh it's
all right for you because you had a
house but the thing is there will always
be people that can either find excuses
or you can say actually but what have i
got going for i mean on windows on a
wednesday some of the people on on the
shows you've seen that i started with
nothing i was homeless and then other
people say i was in a job and i had 50
grand or everyone's everyone's got a
different starting point but the key is
to say where am i
where do i want to go and what's my
fastest route to get there yeah yeah but
it's like with our own home you know me
and my partner and fiance show that
we've worked really hard to to build to
build our money to buy a house to
renovate the house and then to refinance
um so it wasn't easy even doing that
it's not it's like we've just had a
house given to us we've worked you know
our asses off to get that house yeah
that's true yeah yeah that's true what
would be some key lessons you've been
through good times you've had bad times
what you've done is great you're making
you know about six thousand pounds a
month every month through property full
time and property you've got two houses
that you own with a third about to
complete this week and you're 24 bro
yeah yeah what would be some of the key
lessons that you would share to people
watching this um
i think like we said earlier definitely
having the right power team around us
yeah around yeah um
and just believing in yourself because
you know i think over that two months
when i couldn't start a deal i didn't
believe in myself truly i think i was
almost shying away from not doing the
work
and so she just put the work in and you
know hard work always pays off that's so
true and you also you um were the winner
at the was it the crash course yeah yeah
one one yeah what happened
um so it was newcastle crash course i
thought i'd go there you know try and
meet some more new people um
and you set the task of trying to find
the best deal yeah in 20 minutes was it
was 20 minutes
and then we managed to find a cracking
deal in newcastle where i had the
opportunity to develop a house next to a
current house yeah and then 100 pounds
yeah um but i remember the two lads i
had next to me they weren't too short i
was like now we're going to do it we're
going to go up on stage but the funny
thing is is i'll do that at the crash
course and the crash course is a free
training program right so anyone can
come it's free and sometimes i'll set
challenges i'll say hey go and find a
deal right now if the back of what you
learned and the person that finds the
best deal i'll give 100 pounds and
everyone thinks it's about 100 pounds i
think i want to win 100 pounds i want to
win 100 pounds but actually from my
perspective it's not about 100 pound
it's about the lesson because in
actually doing it at the crash course
and actually finding a deal even if you
don't win 100 pounds the lesson and the
scale to be able to find the deal is
worth far more than hundred pounds yeah
and i think sometimes people miss that
people want instant money instant
results instant but sometimes you need
to actually take a couple steps back
whether that might be spending time in
education whether that might be
just going out and viewing a whole bunch
of houses getting rejected you've got to
take a couple step backs to then take 20
30 steps forward and i think some people
they're just not prepared to put the
work in yeah well there's the two lines
i had next to me and one of them now ed
miller he's actually my solicitor now he
actually deals with
some of the deals we do um sort of
completing on so he's really good now
but they were quite comfortable to go up
and hours as well but if you don't go
all you're never gonna have a chance
anyway so let's just go for it what's up
the guy that you partnered with in
newcastle's now ended up being your
solicitor yeah yeah yeah yeah great and
that's again as well people when they
come to the event yeah and i'll and
people might not like it because of it
but i'll force people outside
the person you came with
changed seats and people like wow that's
uncomfortable but if you're not getting
uncomfortable then you're not being
you're not growing um and then as a
result you end up doing joint ventures
building your power team exactly and now
having him part of my team is is so good
having a good solicitor in the team is
so important yeah amazing amazing so
brrs do your sourcing hate demos you've
just about touched on most of the
strategies yeah 24 years old um where
are you living are you renting that now
then where you live no we've we've
bought our own home on the outside and
the outskirts of york oh yeah yeah where
did you buy that i bought that in
december last year is it nice house yeah
it's four bed attached yeah very nice
yeah and so so with that house you're
living plus your two whole ones plus
completely straight that's four houses
so yeah four houses it's 24. yeah
does it feel surreal yeah it does yeah
it just it takes a while to sink in yeah
i think since you're moving so fast it's
like you know
you don't really you don't really pay
attention you should celebrate all these
things but i just get what's natural
natural snacks you know yeah
it's like now we're actually working on
them creating a hmo management company
so the deals we're doing in darlington
we're going to have our own management
company as well so when we offer a deal
to investors we can take out all the
management as well so we can do refurb
management the whole shebang nice what
made you choose darlington
well the hall for me is probably an hour
and a half and darlington's only 45
minutes you're in york and york yeah so
i know darlington is only 45 minutes
like i said and have you know the london
treasury workers 750 their workers are
moving to darlington to be relocated
because the treasury right we've got two
amazon warehouses um they're spending
100 million pound on the train station
of the next five years so right now it's
sort of the time to invest yeah okay so
patch wise you've got is darlington is
that it then is that your patch no
that's i think that's just going to be
for the next maybe a year or so yeah um
i am starting to go a bit further up
north looking at newcastle now because
of the crash course and found good two
deals there just trying to make them
sort of stack i did have an offer
accepted today while driving here as
well congrats
uh rochdale so i'm excited about that
one as well what does your partner see
your partner was really supportive at
the beginning and you wouldn't be here
if it wasn't for her yeah what's her
involvement with the business now
so she's
she's just been massive support and just
supported me through the whole process
and she does take care of you know the
stuff like have moved emails and you
don't realize that when you're out on
the road finding deals you've still got
all the business admin and stuff to sort
out social media as well
um
but yeah she's just been there through
the whole whole process amazing yeah
what's the name of your deal sourcing
company and if anyone wants to get in
touch what's the best way so it's jury
lane property investments um and
facebook is the best way to get contact
in facebook yeah thomas atkinson thomas
atkinson amazing what would you say to
someone watching this um i mean you came
down to the crash course yeah that's
where it all started yeah you've been
back again again since what would you
say to somebody that was uh an avid
watcher of the videos i hadn't
physically been to a crash course what
would your advice be you gotta go
because you can you can watch as many
videos as you possibly can but until you
start building your network and having
people around you you won't really act
on it and you need people to bounce off
yeah yeah so there we have it folks
you've heard step by step exactly how
thomas has built up a portfolio himself
but is also packaging and selling deals
to other people if you want to do the
same thing too it all starts at the
property investors crash course good
news is i'm giving you a free ticket so
in the description there's a link you
can get booked on it's completely free
there's a one pound booking fee just to
check you're a real person and you'll be
able to spend a day with me in person
where you can learn all the ropes of
being a property investor if you want to
come down get booked on do it now
because there's very limited spaces also
please do me a massive favor hit the
like button subscribe to the channel if
you want to see more videos like this
you can check out an entire playlist
here where people have become
financially free again and again and
again but let's see you do the same
thing too i'll see you at the crash
course thanks peace out